it's the option to reduce your carbon
footprint once you die assembly Bill 289
would allow your remains to turn into
soil something like this and right now
six states allow so-called human
composting Mary Jane beliesa here now so
Mary Jane we have these photos behind us
this video how exactly does this work I
think a lot of people have that same
question and you know you can't control
when or how you die but you can control
what can be done with your remains and
Funeral Directors say human composting
is just another burial option that can
also give back to the natural world
losing a loved one is never easy at
Heritage Mortuary it's all about
supporting families during a vulnerable
time we'd love to ensure that families
are taken care of as a funeral director
larnik mickens says it's their
responsibility to educate families on
the available options when it comes to
Cremation burial and even the
possibility of human composting it may
be their wish that they return back to
Mother Nature and a lot of people are
conscious about the environment it's
just one way to stay eco-friendly Nevada
assembly Bill 289 would authorize the
use of natural organic reduction of
human remains and it allows us to
sequester carbon and and do a benefit to
the Earth as our last act with our body
Seth vadal is the CIA CEO of the natural
funeral in Colorado where human
composting became legal in 2021 he has
served over 50 families with this option
about 15 of those families traveled from
other states it's where we place the
body in a vessel and in our case we call
it a chrysalis vessel and it was
designed in-house and it's about the
same dimensions as what we would use for
a grave for green burial in the vessel
the body is surrounded with wood chips
and straw then eventually the body is
broken down by microbes and converted
into soil we're able to offer back to
the family this soil that they can take
and place in their yard or on their rose
bushes if the bill passes Mick and said
she would offer human composting as an
option and understands the pushback due
to religious or cultural reasons and we
need to make sure that each and every
person they share their life and then
they honor it the way that they would
like to honor it
now the average cost for a conventional
burial is around 8 500 human composting
comes in a little bit less than that the
average cost at the natural funeral is
about 7 900 that includes Transportation
paperwork the permitting and biological
conversion into soil